The Android plugin can reduce
the size of your app by stripping out
unused code and resources.
It does this with the help
of a tool called Proguard.
Proguard can do a lot of interesting
stuff including obfuscating your code by
giving all your classes and
methods meaningless names.
Though that's mostly of interest if
you're really worried about your code
being reverse engineered.
For our purposes, the properties we
want to configure on our build type
are minifyEnabled and shrinkResources.
In this project,
we have declared a dependency on
Google's mobile services library.
But we're not actually using
anything from that library.
Proguard is smart enough
to figure that out and
will strip out the unused
code from our APK.
The mobile services library also
includes many resources like drawables
for sign in buttons.
Turning on shrinkResources will
strip out any unused resources.
We've configured two new build types.
One of which has turned on magnification
and resource shrinking and
one of which has not.
Let's check out the relative sizes of
the APK's generated by each filed type.
Let's run the assemble task
to generate both APKs.
If we then go find out APKs in App,
build, outputs, APK.
We see that our big APK is 2.9
megabytes, whereas our shrunk APK,
that was using minification and resource
shrinking, is only 1.2 megabytes.
There's a lot more you can do to
optimize your APK using Proguard.
We've included some resources in the
course code, where you can learn more.